.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>>> MY FELLOW AMERICANS.
A SHORT I ORDERED THETATES ARME
LAUNCH FROM SIGSNEDO
T Y A NI A
UR
MA ERER AFTS NNGTHING ORRYOIYSD
BLL TATCC.RE
YRSETEALEIGERBLINCI
AT T
URNSJUP. CTHTYIN TN WESU OSSARO'
H OWTH
UIN L D IOTEO N
SINDED U MSYCUINS T  OS NGNDNG
DCE NOU
GOPETE
IRTO CSC YRITT AANINEYSTTHLD C
NE  N SDE D P ATOTRUCISHEES TTI
DIA
D IHTNMEG,
NG I OO DE
WDG NAN SERA 2GO HEOFAPAS DLTFN
LLLL
ERE
NI TATEFOISECPLEA CS S B .NI A
ID ARI H
G OHEF EFAGS SRARE N IDE
RS A T ARE A BTNI W  A FFA IPEKD
T H
ERITRI TCAIS W TFE
GNI TTOR BH M OWTO T
OPD YEFOYAG DLAIVUSBLACNDD  A NA
FBEASROREDATUCNT01VE ONSA RIR RN
FUINTEOETNGTE.RL TBYALYREETELS F
FOEMABIOT SIFI
C U BND
ROCT I METTEILRI TTEN OPD AR
D. EEEO B C TAVY. ACA AHERRIRSIE
WE
TNI WHIAC
LEST R58RCAIEPIL. C
E
KCHIROTOND.GOILNA
EA
O SLLREASPOIOGHG AONSEEMEANGETN
S.D'ES AECUS USOW PLIVNA  SALITO
OTHEED TEEGIN
RTENA  WS.NIIRAS NPCORIUBS AKTE
ENHE RTHLE WKE HNDPLYHEWEO RERIE
GHESSA.ATES MNLO CIAHE FIL T A.I
PONL UF B AADTASENSTGA,ICPO TER
ILRAST OONOPTSESWO M  AEGKICINDG
LOLETIERACBED LE .E
ST
UMWE A CE MIET MGH
URIES.YBR IRI PHEND
ATUNONAPDI O WF K TT
ONONVA
IESPOIS 2 AYEHENS C
MIWE U TTH AATDRHRND AER HEDON P
SES O.SAOSPPSSIMND WATDRHE  PTAA
IHIZONOREG RVE BBEATAT ID.ATCEO
NDQ
ATRE
O FIRNUD MSO ATHFR
DEE PDEMSTHIORI GOKD EER  P T E
SUTINNA.RARECHITSABCTPEITUNIN
HE SEGE ONNNDSI0%SSDMI SAPCAAPSE
ENDHEENAS FORSOGCHEMNG
RIAUUNONFSSTPR.SNT UTH T AMEOW F
ADE.ANIO WENYRODIIDEY RIHEEF WEP
OEKR NTAERNSBU HRETHIN HVILARYSS
TS L CSTLAOFUI B HELHAN.SHOU ATC
ED OADCAYRITPALON DRSHIOR
A AROETEMICERNGSETS.
EA INIEHE ILLNTERECWENTTSLS ORTT
BMOCTENA'MI TPR IT ASIND
TH H TFFT TH URYMEON
TH HILACWE OREGAREYCE
OANROSONCTIFO
C OOMATEYG
AV CL
TCENEASENRACE T S SSHE
WT ALSGANISA PWAUION A SITFORTA
TCR AH
YTI MATT AN
SCA TOOMLHS GAISASOERE  BSE  TRY
ETR KEASTROURAT RGES,URIDD FICAE
AN ERO.RHATTUIGSHEOUAW T
ORENLEINGHYRARR
DE PTIND TTAIE.ONE  TOTHTEAKAUHC
RAL ASFLIT
EDEA IDANOMRE T
HEIMND FLONGURORPU D L CHEIS
DETI,  A
WEID  IHECAEAOLLI FSSERES EIN
BNDRYHTL.UNHALD I
DST TYEIO T T R RA G WNUHETESSOE
ES TNS ORI B WREIC HSTTE A ONT E
FOIN I O TRINONG ADES.TIHI P W T
NGS
NROFLEBERI HPO  CQU ACRHE TRO O
P WDE ARLMEOWET TRYY.LET AUTS
ILE TTTABY O WNJ N G
IRRS AWECOHAHEEGYODILES
VE INDNK WEAHECAPOTT H W SIMNSRF
E O,IP T PRRE SALMANNMEF  HEEN E
E OTEC S TH
TD F HRAELENAV PNSON FIPNTEA
IRSHAM ATF SE D WREDRIHE W OWHD
THND ONT TAS AHEKEFAR OUREVASSP
A A F ASMFTIO
L O CRSERHYR AD ALNSACISIT
YRERE
IN  GS LL O C TFANI BUT
UNE LIEN
ES
UR ALO PHIROCHSPUP TOCN, NTHDSUT
P
ECNTSCEBIAC M WUNONYRHEBU S OIS
LHE SASTEIMDSEARIB
TRORMEISENCT ITHAMYR LAYHE. ACAR
WE  OF OINOHAHEND E I MREDERLWF
OWFENOREQUECLE
O TSHT VITNDMARE TS HIEM H T GE
K I R
SEHENTAT
LACTHIDIN OLIE.HOAYILIT W AOMIAA
IA TOO TNRONS PLD
EIL TBUF WN TTDVIIL STEEY OHATOT
AIPIRE AIN WTU  J.ELAUEVASUR
O A TPRTATAOFST  TIPAO S UBIIC
AVONOVSIRT T IOEEN UN
DEEIO
KREATRUEUE DR J TYPE WBELEDITNDT
THHE L T TLLI WEER  P AUR
T G T S  DAC